one of the benefits of having your
seemeth be bright pink is that it stands
out very easily for the reapers to find
you in the middle of the night and then
eat your brains out through your boy
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now in
this episode we will be venturing off to
the place that we said we would never
return because death lurks around every
corner
in all honesty we're going to go back to
the Aurora because now that I have the
welder tool I can fix the Aurora or at
least I can stop the radiation from
leaking but also there is an upgrade in
that generator room that I need to get
to and it is oddly quiet in here and I
think I know why because when I loaded
up my game I went over to check on my
fishies in my fishy tank and you may
notice there's something missing in here
that was a very prominent feature the
last time we were here yep that's right
the egg that I put in here is gone which
I can only assume means that it hatched
and escaped and is currently stalking
the hallways waiting for me to drop my
guard so that it can kill and then eat
me so we all have that to look forward
to but we also have to look forward to
the wall of heroes here so I got three
new names from the comment section thank
you all for helping out the first one is
John Smith no relation to Steven Smith
who said why didn't anyone tell
markiplier that the heated blade can
cook the fish I don't know you're
actually the first person that ever said
that to me so you are super cool I think
I can actually spell your full name in
here and you deserve your own locker I
don't know what I'm gonna shove inside
your locker but it's probably gonna be
useful the next one goes to Amer
awesome I'm probably mispronouncing that
name but thank you so much because you
said that I need the terraform to get
the possible cave opening and I'm
assuming that's the one down deep below
the depths so maybe in the next episode
I'm gonna make that and then we're gonna
go down into the depths of hell and last
one goes to Brendan Kay game gun Brendan
Kickham I'm just gonna gam Brandon kajam
who said Karen is your only friend on
this planet make a rusty bucket for her
living and that one just made me laugh
so
everybody so much for commenting I
really do appreciate you guys following
along the series but now we must venture
off into the abyss in the middle of
night apparently be all good is coming
in today and there is the upgrade in the
Aurora is actually an upgrade to the
Cyclops
which is going to be very important
because I believe even though my seamoth
has about the maximum upgrade for its
depth capacity the Cyclops I think I'm
not a hundred percent sure on this one
but I'm pretty sure that the Cyclops can
go even deeper than the sea moth which
would mean that we would have even more
to explore even though it seemed like we
reached maximum capacity by going to the
end of the game there are actually
deeper points in the game with which to
see so we're gonna find our way there
eventually and hopefully not die because
dying is something that I've been very
very good at over the past few episodes
that I've been playing this I've died a
lot admittedly if I was in a real
scenario where I was trying to survive
when a horrible I'm going the wrong way
on a horrible horrible horrible desolate
where oh ok I was about to say oh god
I'm in Reaper territory by the way I
don't know if I mentioned this but I
finally found out the name of the thing
it's called the Reaper Leviathan which
is a lovely name they they came up with
two different names to name something
horrible and scary and big in the ocean
and then they decided that they couldn't
decide between the two of them so they
named it both the Reaper Leviathan so
hopefully we can skirt around this I
can't see you where the heck am i they
did another update and whenever they do
an update they change things that I'm I
could have sworn I was going in the
right direction and they with what the
hell where did it go again I did not
know I was made of left I don't like
this I'm right in Reaper territory
aren't I
at least I can see the ocean floor again
so that's awfully nice okay everything's
fine
I'll see you on the incent the aurora
alright hey how's it going sand shark
what a doof II do
look at you and listen to the lovely
Rumble did this get smaller I don't get
asked that question a lot shut up it's
gonna park my seamoth in this precarious
burning a hole in the ship and then fly
my way I'm going the wrong way and fly
my way up here excuse me
okay so in here there is the generator
room so this
oh no wait this is not it this is the
generator room so now that I'm in the
generator room I can take my repair tool
which has a good amount of energy to it
and I can actually charge this up
because one of the reasons why I still
have these particular fins is because
this takes energy so when I swim with it
it actually rejuvenates and good thing I
got those first aid kit why is this not
rejuvenating why is is no rejuvenating
oh there it goes it rejuvenates so I got
to find all of the problems with these
and I got to fix them up her prettier
prettier and with this I don't need the
radiation suit anymore which means that
I can get the moisture retaining oh god
ten radiation leaks Karen could you put
them on like a mini map or something pop
them up on my heart thank you or no
Karen I'm gonna get you a rusty bucket
to live in because apparently that's the
best for my computer wife's wives I only
have one Karen what are you sitting what
are you talking about
you're the only love for me baby oh is
it just me or is she getting sassier it
sounds like she didn't like the idea of
me having other computer wives or
computer boyfriends apparently in the
Cyclops
oh well I'll be back once I get all
these welded up okay I'm not sure but I
think I got all of the breaches that are
underwater which means that the rest of
the breaches either have to be above
on the upper areas I'm just scanning
really closely haha
I spotted you you thought you could get
away from me but I'm going to fix all
your problems with fire the same way I
fix all of my emotional problems left
Karen come on
okay I'm gonna look above for him
hopefully we'll get somewhere there's
one I knew it had to be true there's one
more there's just one more so if that
one son of a [ __ ] you are oh hey it's
the son of a [ __ ] I swear these are
appearing randomly and three two one
I'm amazing drive core briefs sealed
radiation dissipation in three days
trying download attempt with roar
particle containment field restored auto
decontamination sequence initiated
hmm Nash elements are estimated to
return to safe levels in t-minus three
days noise oh three days Santos okay
good enough for me that means that this
will soon be safe traverse and I mean
it's already safe to reverse but I also
wanted to explore a little more I may
have already picked up VI can actually
probably check to see if I picked up the
power do daddy blueprint I don't know
I've got the Cyclops hull
what the hell is that have I heard that
before
oh I heard that before alrighty then
that ain't good
apparently okay so I'll be right back
once I finished scouring the rest of
this place just in case there's anything
that I missed but this seems markedly
different okay never mind
I'm back to Iowa so BRB ah [ __ ]
yeah sugar tits sploosh hey oh I don't
think I've explored this area
oh that sounds bad ooh I like the
rumbling it makes me feel very unsafe
hmm
okay okay this seems new and the music
has changed which leads me to believe
I'm either close to my imminent death or
some amazing discovery or neither and
I'm going to be very bored with what I
find oh ho there's nothing here yes
exactly as I planned
BRB okay so apparently now we're on our
own in the blackness so that's nice
what's that
is there anything down here that I
should know about probably not but
anyway the other thing that I need to
conquer and in this area is ha the trail
of debris that extends back behind the
ship but as oh no oh oh okay
how's about to say ah crap but the only
bad thing about that is there's a
big-ass River sandy right there ready to
eat me so the thing about that area is
that there are tons and I mean tons of
supplies there's supply boxes a plenty
strewn across the seabed ready for the
taking
so I need to find a way to get around
the Reaper and then see if I can get
there where whoa where am I where's
where's the goddamn air where's air air
oh no air air air engine see tense
where's the goddamn air oh what what how
did I get oh god please tell me that's
water oh no oh no what
how how did this happen oh god I said oh
my god oh I made it holy crap I didn't
believe in myself for one goddamn second
I gave up already i shy threw in the
towel I'm a quitter on the loser baby
but I survived okay so I'm gonna get
back to my seamoth and then I'm gonna
get back to the base because there
apparently is a gun that I can craft
there's a gun of some sort I don't know
if it's a good gun the propulsion cannon
maybe with that I can shoot things at
the Reaper and kill it but I doubt it's
even possible to kill the Reaper but we
shall see it's always I don't know why I
don't know how and I don't know why but
always whenever I go to the Aurora
everything goes wrong and I nearly have
a heart attack why can't I just have a
nice normal trip to the Aurora where
things are fun and happy and filled with
dreams
hello Sharky poo what are you gonna do
huh you want to mess with me you're
doing backflips to impress me I am NOT
impressed
what this um are you you okay you guys
okay you need some water
I mean you you got plenty of water but
you need some sanity
okay you have fun now you you have fun
you have fun okay onto my ship all over
the place and it's daytime hook gotta
get back to base gotta get back to the
beasts get it drop it to peace but I can
confidently say that I repair the entire
Aurora and everything is a-okay now are
you dead
oh you're not dead where you gonna be
soon bonk oh sorry I'll leave you alone
with a few broken ribs and internal
bleeding that's just the kind of nice
guy I am I bet I can build this base up
a bit more but I'm not quite ready to go
farming again because farming was a bit
of a [ __ ] well not really it was
actually quite peaceful thank you baby
alright so John Smith you're gonna be my
medical man you're gonna cows all my med
kits thank you for that and maybe this
Power Cell in these batteries and also
this aluminium oxide and it's mercury or
I don't even know what the hell that do
but you're gonna keep it and also then
when Mass whoa back up a second land
mass oh oh oh oh oh land mass everyone
said that there was an island available
here and I just got a signal for a land
mass which I don't know if you guys know
what that means but to me that means
Island oh yes we are in a good spot here
also I noticed you need to eat a variety
of food so that you don't just eat only
of one because if you eat too many of
one type of food you will get sick plain
is that I'm gonna put my last whole fish
into my little aquarium I killed and ate
all its friends but it gets to live with
the memory of that but
with new friends that it cares nothing
about okay be free what if I just
dropped a cook what if I just dropped
the cooked fish in here with the rest of
them Oh that'd be so sad
oops I ate it never mind I ate it and
apparently I ate the raw one too well
[ __ ] I didn't mean to do that
I meant to set him free but I forgot to
drop it and said I hate it so anyway
that's all the time that I got for this
episode of subnautica in the next one we
are going to investigate where that
landmass signal goes to and maybe just
maybe find us an island so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
no way you can't detect no fridge okay